juni das geht ab bitte wir sind hier am
start mit kroko crafter sag mal hallo
sagen ausschlag
wir sind hier bei der ersten runde der
holy money boy runde des hannibal
projekts und wir erklären es noch mal
kurz sbc ich erklärt das läuft so wir
lesen uns einander tweets form von boy
for money boy und wer als erstes drei
mal gelacht hat wert verloren so ich
würde mich starten direkt mal mit der
aufwärmrunde und dann mein lieber kroko
kraft doch mal raus wo ich anfangen ja
aber jetzt noch auf wir nehmen jetzt
schlechten witz sagt ich sei ein
schlechter boxer als max schmeling
früher fast werf ich dich bitte über
diesen über diese reding macht meine
yacht okay ich bin ich mein eigener boss
gelacht
ich bin ein gläubiger nein ich bin ein
gründen ich bin ein gläubiger christ der
was bietet für weihnachten dass ihnen
der weihnachtsmann coole geschenke
bringt ok jetzt geht nach punkten wir
haben auch so eingeblendete punkte so
herzen also wer drei mal verliert der
acker der iss hat enorm dort verloren
okay okay ich habe am besten jedes in
die kommentare von dass ihr glaubt wer
gewinnt glaubt ihr dass es kennt oder
das coco kraft gewinnt
ich sage ich werd gewinn schreibt in die
kommentare ja okay okay und muss ihr
chinesisches ex minister heißt es wegen
dein ding woanders hin
dann kann sich schon
da ist ja jetzt bin ich dran es ist
money boy ich bin so ein gläubiger
christ für den ball wieder disc ist eine
rolle gewicht der money boys erfolg zu
vereiteln gedenkt mit morgen in einem
fass voller ertränkte kann ja schon
gesagt nicht durchlesen
ich habe ja von unser letzten test
aufnahme manchmal wer findet ihr ist der
größte [ __ ] riesenwellen sie hier
durch das verbrechen ich mache kann ich
verstehen
abgehakt okay wer findet ihr ist der
größte [ __ ] auf dieser welt das
weiß ich nicht
ja du bist vielleicht wär man bei der
verbreitung von lügen bezichtigt wird
morgen auf der ostseeinsel rügen
beschwichtigt
ja okay ein punkt würde ich einen satz
also wir haben ja noch zwei leben das
war zu einer zeit
wer sagt money boy hat nicht das meiste
geld der welt wird morgen kurz nach 8 in
einem weizenfeld entstehen
die richtige alter zeit
ok also das hat ich hab noch ein leben
egal ob mädchen sind sind schön süß sexy
cruz reggae und geil ganz normale sachen
du wirst es nicht glauben ich kann mit
dem humor von heute nicht anfangen zu
primitiv ich erfreue mich eine subtile
komik in den werken von wilhelm
shakespeare ist ein halber ein halber
braucht einen halben punkt
ich stimme mit mehreren boys in einem
kleinen whirlpool aber nicht wegen
schwul sein sondern um business wire
diesmal alles okay ich schaue mal ob ich
es ein werden kann ist das noch ein
leben darf gar nicht lachen halten
werden
die ganze nation
konzentriert euch konzentration ist
weiter aktuell
damit so es ist freitag der verdienste
und ich tue angst helfen dass freddy
krueger kommt und mich beschützen will
aber das gelingt ihnen nicht auch schon
gelesen weiß ich hab ihn genau vor mir
in der schule war ich immer schlecht in
mathematik ich war der der wo immer auf
einem gymnastik hatte immer schlecht
wenn er macht ich kann zwar nicht drei
mal sechs in meinem kopf rechnen
trotzdem war ein budget sex und meinen
kopf lag die erste runde geht
ach nee du dahin noch gleichziehen
darfst du noch gleichziehen
also nach nein nein dann hat wenn dein
auto an vertriebs aufheben müssen wir
eben street für die nächste folge auf
wann kommt die nächste folge morgen bei
denen keine ahnung müssen wir gucken
wann wir wieder aufnehmen können
in den nächsten tagen wissen wir alle
beschränkt ihr business männer und ja
leute dann würde ich sagen haltet die
augen offen
haltet die ohren steif dem oscar und die
nächste mal über runde
wenn es euch gefallen hat dann schreibt
hashtags weg in die kommentare
und last ein leichter und ja dann würde
ich sagen
haut rein